bonjour michel raimbault merci de
répondre à nos questions face à cette
urgence sanitaire mondiale est ce qu'il
y à une urgence politique à assouplir
les sanctions économiques qui pèsent sur
certains pays on a vu comme les
etats-unis vis-à-vis de l'iran ou encore
du venezuela
oui certainement qu'il ya une gamine
l'urgence très très grande
et en plus sur l urgence à respecter le
droit international puisqu'il et ses
fonctions par du sang sont ils s'en sont
illégales elles sont criminels dire
certains experts des nations unies les
assimilent à des crimes contre
l'humanité voire même bug avec une
tendance génocidaire barre soit
concernant les sanctions contre l'iran
ou dial venezuela
sans parler de cuba qui est depuis 60
ans l'objet de sanctions et je crois que
globalement on ne peut pas croire les
autorités qu'on attend le président
trump parler de la période épouvantable
qui s'annonce pour les états unis
d'amérique
oui certainement mais c'est pas parce
que le peuple américain ne doit pas
souffrir qu'il doit faire souffrir tous
les peuples de la planète
je rappelle quand même que toutes les
sanctions américaines en général soit
illégal son lit latéral et à ton
contraire au droit international
ensuite elle s'exerce de façon persiste
ce sont des invisibles et cruel qui
passe par dix ans des pressions sur les
sociétés pour empêcher en fait pour
équipier pour introduire un véritable
blocus
c'est le cas sur la syrie c'est le cas
sur l'identification le venezuela
c'est le cas sur cuba par exemple j'en
veux pour preuve le fait que sur que
cuba il ya un avion chinois qu'avec à ce
raid est apprêté à destination de cuba
pour par un homme d'affaires chinois
avec un transporteur américain
finalement n'a pas pu atterrir à cuba le
transporteur s'étant désistés parce
qu'ils les américains qu'il a peur des
sanctions de son propre pays contre cuba
je pense que par exemple dans le cas du
cud cubaine une nappe
on parle souvent une sanction contre
l'iran ces deux là ont pu assimiler
largement celles qui sont en cours sur
le venezuela je pense qu'en semencière
le venezuela et cuba
il s'agit de deux cas spécifique puis
que sont le plus bas ces deux pays
constituent de véritables provocations
vivante dix ans quant à l'encontre des
états unis puisque cuba est l'objet de
sanctions depuis 60 ans et qu' il a pu
développer une médecine de pointe il le
contribuer activement à la lutte contre
le canadien russe dans
en pays de la planète et donc ceci
constitue une véritable provocation par
washington devant le venezuela je pense
que le venezuela est l'objet d'une
tentative de changement de régime pas
seulement à bien avant l'épidémie du
grenat virus je crois que les états unis
ne cachent pas leur souhait de renverser
le président a juré de le renverser à un
de le remplacer par un homme qui serait
à leur botte je crois depuis le temps du
régime de mugron chavez c'est ça la
hantise des états unis de faire revenir
le venezuela dans le camp américain
chose que le venezuela ne veut pas et
maï maï pompéo assure je cite évalué
constamment toutes ces politiques est ce
que washington pourrait alléger ces
sanctions pendant cette crise sanitaire
mondiale sociaux et la sagesse mais on
nous on attend plus de sagesse de la
part de washington de la part de
monsieur pompéo de monsieur trump et
consorts je crois que c'est on peut
toujours attendre longtemps mais on peut
vivre d'espoir l'essonne alors alors
selon vous comment est ce que ces pays
aux systèmes sanitaires fragile
pourrait faire face à l'épidémie comment
comment les aider si ces sanctions ne
sont pas levés comme le réclame l'onu va
écouter madame bachelet la commissaire
aux droits de l'homme par exemple aux
nations unies a appelé à alléger les
sanctions toutes les sanctions contre
tous les pays qui en sont victimes
notamment les sanctions américaines
encore une fois parce que celui des
actes des entorses au droit
international et que ce ne serait que
même pas un geste le chari crévoux de
bienveillance à serait seulement
respecter le droit mais malheureusement
peu plus respecter le droit de 6 a plus
droit international alors donc je crois
que on il est vain d'attendre je pense
que ça n'est qu' des forces mondiales
le personne ne peut se cacher l'idée que
finalement l'un des éléments principaux
l'un des impacts principaux de la crise'
coronavirus il ya son impact sanitaire
et dont et et son impact des dix ans un
peu de terrifiant mais deuxièmement il
contribue ce n'est pas lui la cause
principale mais contribue va devenir
l'un des éléments principaux finalement
de l'un des impacts principaux de
l'épidémie grenat virus d'un changement
de l'ordre mondial
il est clair que les états unis d'une
part l'union européenne d'autre part qui
préfèrent s'aligner sur les états unis
notamment ce qui concerne les sanctions
sur le venezuela
c'est une position qui a été prise en
disant que le processus ne mendie qu'ils
appellent transition démocratique
c'est-à-dire de changement de régime au
venezuela étaient conformes aux
principes de l'union européenne ils sont
vraiment pas très difficile mais disons
je pense que tout ceci dit long ils ont
donné une triste image disons de leur
comportement à la fois dans la gestion
des crises qui prône un virus qui ça
c'est devenu les foyers principaux de
l'épidémie de la pandémie
et puis deuxièmement de leur
comportement vis-à-vis des pays d autres
séries puisque voilà
et donc ces quelques sollicitations qui
est très très lamentable on ne voit pas
très bien issue il faudrait qu'il ya une
issue un merci michel rampeau d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes essayiste et ancien
ambassadeur de france